Matt you've been studying the
libertarian party in all of its
different incarnations for many many
years now where do you think
Libertarians are likely to Cluster now
given the sort of weird and changing
presidential field uh we have no idea
and it's also like small L and capital L
are different things I mean small L
Libertarians like those of us with
libertarian Persuasions who may or may
not be mythed by the direction of the lp
the uh it's funny you know I the people
who know about the direction of the lp
right who know about the misus caucus uh
self-described takeover that happened
that Zach covered so well um in the past
and and in an ongoing basis really um
that is known by People Like Us who are
very online Libertarians I'm not sure
that it's known by the 750,000 Americans
who were registered as Libertarians
which is by the way three times the
number as it was 20 years ago um which
is pretty significant Libertarians are
on a uh three presidential election
bronze medal streak uh which is
definitely a tallest dwarf category uh
situation but also like we haven't seen
any party do that since the 19th century
when it was the Socialists um so by far
they will have the most uh uh
presidential ballot access of any third
party um it's remains to be seen what
happens with Robert F Kennedy Jr um and
how many ballots he get he's doing a mix
of his own name and and like hijacking
or creating other parties to get on
there and I think all of that is one of
the um the most underrated part of this
uh campaign I I presume that we're going
to see a lot more thought and activity
about that in the very near future
certainly um uh depending on what
happens to Nikki Haley in the next two
main uh primaries Nevada has a caucus
and she's not even competing um but uh
there there is such a huge sentiment
Robert F Kennedy Jr is polling at 15%
that's crazy we haven't seen that from
an independent since Ross perau um you
still have Dean Phillips and Maryanne
Williamson uh polling combined above 10%
against Joe Biden and no one's paying
any attention to them at all um there's
even an outside chance that Dean
Phillips might uh might be a thorn in
Biden's Side in New Hampshire it's all
weird with Ry and stuff there's all this
uh ferment happening Americans hate this
election and they have from the
beginning and it's it's now looking even
more like the thing they've wanted to
hate both Biden and Trump are underwater
among Independents who were always the
Swing Vote in presidential elections um
Biden won last time and people tend to
forget this he won because the people
who voted third party in 2016 uh the
majority of whom were Libertarians
voting or at least voted Libertarians uh
he won because those people didn't vote
for third party they voted for him um
the the percentage of the third party
vote in 2016 was 5.7 uh in uh 2020 was
1.8 and what did the Democrat do uh
compared to Hillary Hillary Clinton he
went up by three percentage points so
it's pretty clear that's what happened
people freaked out about Trump they
didn't like him Independence soured on
Trump from the moment he was elected
just as they have with Biden by the way
Biden actually had a higher ranking
among Independents when he was
inaugurated like 61% and then it plunged
to 34 within six months um and it it
remains there so when we talk about
where Libertarians going to vote um we
have to I think um understand that uh
Libertarians at least for the last three
presidential elections they just kind of
vote libertarian I'm not sure how much
they know uh that there's all these
feuds within misus caucus and non- misis
caucus there's lawsuits at the state
party level and all this kind of stuff
it might be something that interests
them and it might also be something they
haven't even begun to hear about and
that they have just created their own
political identity as Libertarians and
if they see that word on a ballot go
okay vote for that um so we don't know
my so my observation of the very online
Libertarians was a decent amount of
enthusiasm for v um I mean I ran an inal
poll on my Twitter so take that for what
it's worth and he was the kind of you
know plurality getter on uh you know who
is there like which candidate would uh
be most beneficial to your personal
Liberty
um and it just kind of confirmed what
I'd been seeing a lot a bunch among a
lot of online
Libertarians um now that vake is out uh
what do you make of that that VI love
among certain segment of the libertarian
movement uh what do you think accounts
for it and where might it
go well I mean he wants it to go to
Donald Trump obviously he's now asking
demand I don't think it's going to
necessarily um well it's not that he has
a a large following to begin with you
know he's polling nationally like four
or five uh percent in a Republican
primary the Iowa uh the libertarian
party did do like an Iowa cockus thing
there's a very small number of votes but
um pulled that up too I'll pull that up
uh Chase Oliver got the most Chase
Oliver that's an underrated story right
um in that uh people have been talking
about the misus cockus Takeover and this
and that and the other Chase Oliver to
my knowledge and I haven't been
following the lp very closely so far
this cycle he's not a misas kakas guy
that's not where he's coming off like
he's a two-time yeah candidate who's
pushed uh uh Democratic Republican uh
elections in Georgia into runoffs twice
um he seems to sort of clean up and
present pretty well as a former military
I I believe um but that poll is also
interesting because vivec ramas swam got
four times as many votes as Jacob
hornberger uh Jacob hornberger who last
time was the runner up in the
libertarian party he was and it was also
the misaka choice or at least the um by
you know compared to Joe Jorgenson and
she won uh kind of come from behind
Victory against Jacob hornberger uh this
could be just an outlier and it could
you know there was talk of that VC's
name got on that ballot through an odd
way to begin with um yes I saw some math
whz figuring out that uh if that those
like 1%
1.1% uh numbers represent like one vote
that about like 89 people voted in this
of 99 counties so yeah so it's it should
gra of salt but there are dozens of us
dozens dozens literal dozens vvec vivec
says things that some people like to
hear which is that um you know January 6
was an inside job and that the election
of 2020 is stolen of of course that's in
direct contradiction to what he said
about the 2020 election literally 14
months ago which was that people who are
uh complaining that it's stolen don't
have any evidence and that they're
they're the ones drinking copium uh and
that it's unseemly and they're becoming
the grand old party of crybabies but you
know whatever we all we all change with
new data I guess um uh there are people
who like that and also like his very
like bold provocative ideas about
foreign policy sort of a radical semi
anti-ar or anti-us intervention
depending on how you look at it type of
things like he will negotiate with
Vladimir Putin to give chunks of Ukraine
uh to Russia in return for making sure
that Russia and China don't cooperate
and if they do break that then Ukraine
goes into NATO and I guess there's an
audience for that um uh do you make a
like that like what like tear that
argument apart for me because it seems
um a little bit Josh Barrow has the
Great Piece about I believe it's Jos
barro about how VC is basically section
guy um at any fancy School you always
see these people people in college the
people who are always in a hurry to
raise their hand and they think they
know the answers to absolutely
everything and there's this um this ego
this narcissism the sense of hubris and
that they have all the answers to
everything when I look at Vic's
typically Twitter posts on foreign
policy that talk about how actually
he'll just solve China uh and he'll just
make it so Putin and China
Cooper it always strikes me as I don't
know like a 19-year-old LARPing as a
foreign policy expert Matt you have way
more experience in this what do you make
of it
just no president has the magic wand um
and we should have learned that from
Donald Trump um of all things I mean you
know he was going to use the magic wand
to build wall or you know extend the
wall uh on the southern border and it
extended somewhat but the magic wand
doesn't exist it's hard to get stuff
done and it's hardest of all to get
stuff done in the international Arena so
the less that you know about it and the
more that you're going in there with
Instinct rather or just you know a
feeling of vibe rather than knowledge of
how Powers interact with one another the
more that someone uh imagining magic
wand sounds great um and without and
without like a backup plan I mean we're
living in a populous moment in the
United States and the globe and we have
been for about 10 years and there's a
lot of the part of that instinct is a
correct one in my view which is that the
way that the world is ordered um doesn't
have as much Democratic legitimacy seems
to be happening regardless of whether
one wants it or not that's the always
the fertile ground for conspiratorial
thinking and I I use that nonpor in this
case um uh if you're trying to figure
out why this policy or these conditions
these decisions keep happening and your
vote has nothing to do with it your your
attitudes have nothing to do with it
then you start developing some theories
uh about that because it seems like you
you are powerless I mean you see this a
lot in Western Europe for example
because the world order is something
that Western Europe hasn't had a lot of
influence on it's the United States that
pretty much has the most influence on it
and so the average French person is
going to think uh all kinds of
conspiratorial things about um how these
decisions get made and where and by who
um so Vic plays into that or like he
Taps into that I should say uh that
sentiment that feeling like if we just
withdraw from NATO and if we just do
this do this then something that has
never been uh thought of before can
happen happen um it's just naive it's
not how structures and parties work I I
would say like one way of thinking about
it is um uh is brexit Right brexit makes
total sense from just like a sovereignty
kind of point of view right um and the
people who are pushing brexit had all
kinds of very uh naive ideas about what
would happen afterwards um they actually
didn't have a very good plan for that
and then brexit's still kind of a big
mess afterwards and the results were not
what the people who were pushing for or
it promised or wanted um it's a lot
easier to say you know to quote Steve
Martin I break with the I break with the
and you throw dog poop on somebody's
shoes than it is to build what replaces
the postor War II order um so if your
instinct is like well just that
order um then then vivec ramaswami is
good and there's a lot of people who
have that instinct um and uh and would
rather just Express that than try to
construct what comes next hey thanks for
watching that clip from our new show
just asking questions you can watch
another clip here or the full episode
here new episodes drop every week so
subscribe to reent TV's YouTube channel
to get notified when that happens or to
the just asking questions podcast on
Apple Spotify or any other podcast